الى تطورات الازمه في كوسوفو حيث تواصل
الاقليه الصربيه الاحتجاج امام مقر ثلاث
بلديات في شمال البلاد يطالب المحتجون
بسحب تعزيزات الشرطه من امام المباني
العامه وعدم السماح لرؤساء البلديات من
اصول البنيه المنتخبين اخيرا بالدخول الى
المقر وقال رئيس وزراء كوسوفو البنكورتي
انه يسعى للدفاع عن كل صرب كوسوفو مؤكدا
ان من حقهم ايصال صوتهم بطرق السلميه
واضاف ان السلطه في كوسوفو يمكن الحصول
عليها بالانتخابات وليس بالعنف
معنى من
متروفيتا شمالي كوسوفو مراسله الجزيره
محمد المدهون اذن يبدو ان التوتر ما زال
مستمرا لكن كيف يبدو الوضع امام مقر
البلديات التي يطالب الصرب بعدم
سماح العمد المنتخبين بدخولها
الحمد لله الحمد لله الله يتقبل الط
اعات السدس للاحتجاجات الاوضاع تبدو هادئه
على الارض لكن اسباب التوتر ما تزال قائمه
في اي لحظه يمكن ان يتغير الوضع صحيح اننا
لم نشهد عنفا مشابها لمشاهدناه في مطلع
هذا الاسبوع ذلك ربما بسبب الضغوط الدوليه
والاوروبيه الكبير بسبب رده الفعل الهائله
بسبب اعلان الناتو ارسال 700 جندي اضافي
يعلم الطرفان الان الصربي والكوسوفي ان
العالم يتابع وان هناك محاوله لالقاء
اللوم على اي منهما ولكن اسباب التوتر ما
تزال قائمه ما زال رئيس وزراء كوسوفو يرفض
المطلب الامريكي والاوروبي بسحب عربات
الشرطه والقوات الخاصه التابعه لشرطه
كوسوفو من محيط هذه المقر وما زال
المحتجون يتوافدون الى محيط هذه المقار
وحقيقه هناك انتقال للخلافات البينيه داخل
المشهد السياسي الكوسوفي هناك جلس قائمه
في البرلمان الان رئيس الوزراء البينغورتي
يستمع الى الكثير من الانتقادات حتى ان
احد زعماء الاحزاب المعارضه المعارضه دعا
الى نزع الشرعيه عن حكومته ونزع الثقه
عنها وقال ان كورتي بقراراته بعناده هذا
ورط البلاد مع الحلفاء وانه يخدم في
الحقيقه صربيا من خلال تعنده ورفضه سحب
قوات الشرطه من محيطي مقر البلديات هناك
نقاش داخلي قائم ولكن رئيس الوزراء يبدو
انه سيلبي المطلب الاول ابدى جاهزيه
لتلبيه المطلب الاول الذي اعلنه الجزء
بوريل هناك ثلاثه مطالب من الجهتين
الصربيه والكوسوفيه المطلب الاول تنظيم
انتخابات محليه في اقرب وقت ممكن في هذه
البلديات الاربع قال كورتي انه يستمع
لصربي كوسوفو وانهم انتظاهروا سلميا فانه
سيستمع لمطالبهم بما يعني انه سيقبل
باجراء انتخابات اخرى ولكن من يضمن ان
يشارك ه
في هذه الانتخابات هذا امر على كاهل هل
ستقبل صربيا بذلك هل ستدفع الصرب هنا في
هذه البلديات شماليه كوسوفو الى المشاركه
والقبول بانتخابات تشرف عليها حكومه
كوسوفو والمطلب الثالث هو البدء بتاسيس
رابطه البلديات الصربيه البلديات ذات
الاغلبيه السلبيه في شمال كوسوفو واعطائها
بعض الحكم مستوى من الحكم الذاتي خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالتعليم وقطاع الصحه والتخطيط
المدني والريفي والعمراني كل هذه الجوانب
يريد هؤلاء الصرب الذين يعيشون في هذه
البلديات هنا ان يكون لهم نوع من الحكم
الذاتي والقرار المستقل بشان كل هذه
القضايا وهذا الامر كان مطروحا امس في
الاجتماع الذي عقده الرئيس الفرنسي
والمستش الالماني مع الرئيس الكوسفيه
والرئيس الصربي وهذا الاجتماع لم يكن
متوقعا حسن كان مفاجئا ويظهر مدى الضغوط
التي يبذلها الاتحاد الاوروبي تحديدا
الرئيس الفرنسي والمستشار الالماني على
الجهتين من متروفيتا شمالي كوسوفو مراسل
الجزيره محمد المدهون شكرا جزيلا لك